I was also curious about clay dirt and
eating it and your own family connection
to that the title of the film comes from
a conversation I had with my grandma
around the practice of eating clay DT
and I actually wrote a poem first with
that title that has nothing to do with
the film years before I even knew I
would come to this film believe it or
not the film didn't even with that title
didn't always have the clay dirt eating
in it oh wow it was something I came to
like the it felt like the film wanted
that title it's often after rain when
the earth smells so rich that those who
practice eating clay dirt eat it and I
didn't grow up eating clay dirt my
mother did though and my my grandma did
her you know it was passed down when a
film that deals so much with tradition
and what's passed down from generation
to generation it felt like a detail that
speaks to it all which that's what
really uh inspired me to add it right
right